well we can speak now to the former
conservative mp and education secretary
justin greening great to have you on the
programme uh today morning sophie
yesterday was pride and back in 2016 you
chose that day to tweet
today is a good day to say i'm in a
happy same-sex relationship i campaigned
for stronger in but sometimes you're
better off out i absolutely love
this photo of you i have to say
um how important was that moment for you
i mean it was it was life-changing in a
way um
i've been a cabinet minister for quite a
while
and
not being frank about my relationship
had re i genuinely felt it had held me
back i didn't feel like doing interviews
on you know my personal life as much as
i possibly would have done and i
realized that i had to become part of
the solution
and i couldn't think of a better time
to do that tweet than on the day of
london pride back in 2016 it was
actually as you alluded to just after
the the eu referendum and
really from that moment on i just think
for me it was like a weight off my
shoulders and
you know i do so much campaigning now on
leveling up and social mobility but i
think you know you can't be at your best
if you can't be yourself and so
for me life got a lot better when i i
could be myself
i find it
quite hard i guess in some ways to
really understand that you know you're
someone who is an incredibly successful
woman you're confident you've been a
cabinet minister you've done numerous
interviews including on this show for
many years
and yet you felt
that it it did take quite a long time
for you to in your words to be yourself
yeah i just think it's why things like
london pride and all those other
you know marches and celebrations um
around the country matter because
actually we're on a journey and and i'm
gonna guess
there may be some i was a cabinet
minister
watching other people like david mundell
say this is who i am
and so
yes at the end of the day
it is a very personal um thing to do but
i also think it was up to people like me
to show some leadership almost if you
weren't part of the solution then you
were part of the problem you were sort
of saying you thought there was a
problem with your relationship and i
really don't think there is
so i all i would say is it was a hugely
positive step for me there's a lot more
campaigning to be done on lgbt plus
rights on on that um what campaigning do
you think needs to be done what issues
well we've seen homophobic hate crime
rise actually quite significantly over
the past four years i think when you
look at access to healthcare
mental health issues
there's a whole range of
different aspects i think for the lgbt
plus community
that
people would like to see better
addressed but also i think when you look
at say for example women's rights over
in the states and the rolling back of
roe v ward
on abortion rights now discussions
around whether that will translate
across other rights
like for the lgbt plus community i think
just this underlying assumption in the
past maybe the rights generally get
better but that's not always the case so
we have come a long way we've now got
same-sex marriage you can have adoption
obviously as well all sorts of things
but actually we shouldn't just assume
that we won't get pushed back and i
think that's why pride yesterday and all
of the campaigning that people do
matters so much it's interesting about
that um you know kind of rights under
attack if you that feeling um are you
concerned about same-sex marriage in the
u.s
well only time will tell but it really
worries me
that you can have a country like the
states with its democracy
and then
judges who have been ultimately
political appointees almost randomly
over different presidential
terms depending on who died when with so
much power
and i think
then the challenge is yes of course
codify these rights in legislation but
if you also then have a
stateside politics and democracy that is
often gridlocked
spit half and half down the line between
republicans and democrats then it is
hard for them to actually do that so
you're just left with a supreme court
taking away rights but a political
system not able to put them in place for
the long term where they should be in
law on roe versus wade and um
are you concerned about the what it
means to the uk we've seen of course
some mps calling for the right to an
abortion to be included in the british
bill of rights
i think it puts a question out there
that none of us really
had anticipated which is that women's
rights
may be pushed back
when actually the debate is how do we
move them forward still so i hope that
within parliament surely there has to be
a consensus
that it's a question of how you move
forward not moving backwards but i think
what the states tells us is that we
can't just assume that and i think for
not just female parliamentarians but but
you know men and women the cross-party
consensus as well that we've had
i think it's time to redouble those
efforts whether it's on gender pay gap
and some of those policy areas that
government's got whether it's the
campaigning around um
around abortion whether it's around just
generally seeing women do better across
society all of those things really
really matter i think
um
at the beginning when i was talking to
you about you know different campaigns
for lgbt you mentioned homophobic hate
growing going up which is again
something that in the research the
interview
i saw and actually was quite sort of
shocked by i guess and it's not what i
had expected you kind of think that
these things will just progressively get
better
but why it may be an impossible question
but why do you think it does seem as
though these crimes are going up
i think
i think it's because
there
there are people in every country but
including ours who just think this has
all gone too far
and and in spite of all of the broader
progress
um across the mainstream in a sense of
society
there are some parts of
our society who just don't accept that
and the problem is i think particularly
also in an internet age they're able to
sort of find one another and have those
conversations and self-validate them
which is why it does really matter that
you keep the fight going on lg lgbt plus
rights
um
now that i have you i do need to ask you
obviously about the allegations in the
conservative party and we've seen of
course the resignation of chris pincher
um teresa's coffee said that the prime
minister wasn't aware of in her very
careful language specific allegations
when he was appointed to be
deputy chief whip in february um
is that good enough
well look i think any time you end up
with an mp embroiled in these sorts of
allegations one of two things is going
to happen either the mp themselves will
take responsibility
and own it and work out what they do
next or it ends up being the party led
by a prime minister so one of those two
things is going to happen either
chris pincher as we get to the bottom of
these allegations will have to take
responsibility and decide what he does
but if that is not done then yes it will
reflect on the wider conservative party
particularly in parliament
led by boris johnson and that's why i
think for a lot of the parliamentary
party this comes back to
boris johnson's leadership now the way
out of this in the long term setting
aside what needs to happen on this
particular case
is to do exactly what caroline knows
karen bradley to highly respect to
senior female parliamentarians have
suggested which is to get a code of
conduct in place so we are not seeing a
prime minister and a party having to
just decide on the hoof
in each specific case it is a clear
process that people go through and then
everybody is
transparent and clear cut about what
would happen next and it is now time to
put this on a much firmer footing you
say time to put it on a firmer footing
because as you say this is not really an
isolated case we've had five conceptual
mps resigning or being suspended in the
last year
for allegations of sexual uh misconduct
it's pretty extraordinary really is this
now having an impact on the effectively
the brand of the conservative party
i think in the end
it's all it's all about delivery boris
johnson has an agenda of leveling up
delivering equality of opportunity he
has to get on with that
but i think if people feel that delivery
isn't happening fast enough and then
they see these other aspects of how the
party is behaving in parliament and it
gives you this sense that actually
there's not a focus on that delivery for
for joe public like there needs to be
then it it creates this broader
impression of
a party that's in government but not
really driving this country forward
which is absolutely
what we need right now britain has had
long-term persistent systemic
inequality of opportunity
and it will take leadership drive energy
and policy
to change that
and that's why it's so important that
there are some clear decisions taken
about these sorts of cases so that the
government can get on
with that agenda for which i actually
think there is cross-party
support but at the moment
of course it feels like attention is
anywhere apart from that
um just finally uh going back to the
start of the interview um you obviously
came out of pride were you there
yesterday i wasn't able to be there
yesterday because i had a family
birthday so it was probably one of the
first years i've missed it since that
tweet but i'll look forward to being
there
uh next year
definitely very common
photos they were absolutely fantastic
thank you so much it's great to talk
justin greening there thank you